in just a few days voters will go to the
polls for the first time since labour's
red wall
turned blue elections amid parliament
are often difficult moments for the
governing party
but the conservatives are sitting
comfortably this time the tables are
turned
its labor and its leader under pressure
unless he can show that he can reverse
not just hold his place but reverse the
roads that we've already made into the
red wall
i think people within his own party will
really start asking the question
is this sort of metropolitan
representing the elite leader
the person who can win the red wall back
for labour and i think the answer to
that
sadly for kyocerma is absolutely not
when you've come up here are you
recognized or do people still
not know who you are oh it depends out
in east lancashire
kirsten knows he's up against it you're
going to have a really bad election
aren't you
look we're sailing into a very strong
headwind because
um there's undoubtedly a vaccine bounce
for the government
but we've lost four elections and
therefore over a longer term
there's been a sense um that the labour
party is not close enough to those
communities to those that we want to
vote for us and that's what we've got to
do to close that gap and re-establish
that
now i do think that can be done in one
general election cycle and that's what
we are doing
the key red rule fights for you are the
westminster mayor
the tease valley mayor and hartley paul
if you lose all three of them how
serious the trouble are you in as a
leader
i've got a huge task ahead of me there's
no doubt
taking the labour party from where we
were the worst results since 1935
in december 2019 into a position where
we can win an election
is a huge task it is going to take
time i never thought that we could
achieve that in one year i don't think
anybody realistically thought
we could do it in one year but i do
believe that we're making progress and
heading in the right direction
these elections will be the first chance
for the public to give their verdict on
kierstama
since he was elected labour leader just
over a year ago
he likes to say that the party's under
new leadership
but the question is have the public
really noticed and if they have
do they like what they see excuse me
hi i'm i'm beth from sky's just
wondering that man over there do you
know who he is
the guy over there no no it's kierstarma
right do you know who he is no idea okay
a year in the job sir kia is struggling
to cut through to voters
kirsten was up here today i don't know
if you heard he was out and about
what do you think of him to be honest i
think he's just another one yeah
so they're all of the same similar breed
going to do the same similar job
i don't know if kiersten was making that
much of an impact it doesn't seem to
have made much of an impact on you
i think it's down to individual
characters and there is
still the big divide of westminster and
the rest of the world
but some politicians have made their
mark to be honest they're quite like
boris johnson as a character
i think he's borderline semi-normal
the pandemics made normal politics all
but impossible
in times of crisis the public have
little patience for party posturing
but how labor fares in its traditional
heartlands will be
its acid test it's in their old red wall
where they must prove they can build
back
beth rigby sky news